[Music]
Horniman answer one of the most iconic
staples when it comes to Shonen anime
and manga and if it wasn't obvious
everyone before i love tour de Menards
being such a common trend however it may
be possible for an outsider looking at
the excitement we feel whenever one is
announced four theories that we love and
asked what's so exciting about a
cornermen heart
contains some of the hyper and
well-loved instances to come out of
anime and as a story arc is a very
simple and effective way to set up
exciting moments but while it's easy to
set up it's not always easy to pull off
and there are many things that can go
wrong enter my hero academia being one
of the hottest Shonen anime to come out
in recent times my hero academia has
taken shown in battle anime back to its
roots doing nothing revolutionary
besides playing off the appeal and
strength of this genre but refining
everything to a glorious polished tee so
it's no surprise that its latest attempt
at at autumn laughs just happens to be
one of my favorite ornaments in recent
times as it does almost everything an
arc like this should and does it
brilliantly so today let's break down
exactly how to pull up one of the most
beloved tropes in this medium correctly
what makes a good tournament arc I won't
let you down before we get into how to
do it correctly we first need to break
down why the concepts of Atonement arc
work so well in the first place
and this is the first thing to clear up
a tournament is a competition
competition follow sports the Super Bowl
is a tournament are the World Cup is a
tournament heart health the [ __ ]
Olympics is hundreds of simultaneous
tournament hearts the people watching
sporting events after hundreds of years
suddenly goes yeah I'm actually bored of
the setup of these competitions of
course not
at the core level competition and
tournaments are exciting for expect ATAR
because you can weave in countless
amount of narratives into the structure
in a very short time span heroes
villains
teamwork friendships rivalries lineage
and of course the all-important underdog
stories something that was basically
built for a shown in battle jointer
which is also why every sports anime is
essentially just one massive tournament
mark keep in mind that at its core the
hives and hopes of any tournament it's
something that many people experience
and pretty much anything can be turned
to a competition if you invested in the
activity so even if you don't give a
[ __ ] about sports build up your
investment in an activity and you can
give a [ __ ] about competition so for the
purpose of this video when I say
tournament I mean a series of structured
one-on-one matches these could be a
fighting match cooking match team sports
match even a match about drawing manga
but I will be excluding any free throws
and desk tournaments as I feel
something entirely different with this
in mind let's take a look at how the
structure of a tournament can play to
show in an anime fest strength if done
correctly three tournament competition
is the contest that happens just before
the actual main tournament think of the
first tuning exams or the earlier hunter
exams and in academia case it's the
first two games of the sports festival
while not exactly part of the tournament
I'm not present in every tournament art
I believe it can be a very useful tool
for setting up the pieces needed to make
the main event shine the advantage of
having a pre-tournament competition is
that it can help you to set up the
stakes for the main event
introduce a bunch of new characters
around the power levels of each
character and build up hype and
anticipation now all this can also be
achieved in one big long tournament as
you huckster did with this dark
tournament mark but what I like about
having this pride contest is that you
can get rid of a lot of the fluff needed
to set up a good climax allowing you to
shorten the actual tournament so you're
less likely to wear out the format of
one-on-one battles as much as that
people really don't care about my hero
academia actually has one of the
shortest tournaments as shown in battle
animes but that doesn't matter because
the main event itself is so densely
packed with interesting and fun fights
that is constantly entertaining and
never once gets boring and that's
because it manages to hit each of these
four points before the tournament even
begins
think about how all the personal stakes
are set up before the main tournament
you have the triangular rivalry between
Deku Todoroki and Barca established
right at the start and Todoroki in
particulars we never saw much of
previously becomes one of the main focus
of this entire are we are showing the
backstory of why he's so driven to beat
dec who without the use of his father's
powers leaders rejection of dec whose
friendship see him as a rival for
Erica's determination to do well fish
could spoil her family and this puts the
pieces up for all these individual
narratives to clash within the main
tournament yours your core this is the
stage that's also grateful introducing a
bunch of new characters see when you
started kind of Arc it's more likely
than not that your pre-established cast
is not diverse enough to make for an
interesting tournament completely by
themselves the new characters need to be
introduced to either compete for first
place or throw in a few curveballs here
and there a competition like this is a
great way for the audience to
familiarize themselves with a group of
new characters and allow them to make an
impression before the main tournament
rolls in you get rid of the need for
adding in useless fodder into the main
event and instead
these characters to shine in different
ways without having to play everyone's
least favorite pointless game get these
important characters from a character
design it's beyond the card fights in
the boxing match the supporting acts and
a gig you never play your cards here and
you're building up anticipation but that
doesn't mean they can't be great moments
before the main tournament you keep it
interesting by lying a glimpse into
people's abilities without them directly
competing against each other in battle
but in the activity itself whether they
are directly or indirectly fighting in
this activity it builds up anticipation
for the time that they are actually
allowed to battle one another in a map
what it does is allow different
characters to have many victories and
the fees here in their giving us the
audience reasons to speculate who is
more powerful than who in the end who
are the favorites who are the underdogs
and Dark Horse's it establishes a rough
fearless in our mind before the
tournament starts and this is the exact
setup you need as with any real sporting
event to allow for exciting showdown to
come which speaking of which I am not
done yet
[Music]
at the end of the day a tournament is
just a format but as a format it allows
you to do many things in a short period
of time have lots of consecutive battles
of one get the opportunity to see a lot
of interesting matchups and weaving in
many individual narratives into one
place for where most toyman arcs fail to
stand out is by only trying to
acknowledge the first point having many
consecutive battles in the short Simon
sanctions that that will be enough to
keep the audience engaged option without
meaning gets boring fast and much like
fight scenes tournaments are about the
psychology telling a story through the
combat to be individual ideals reasons
for fighting and general mindsets are
all good things writers will flesh out
and make instantly recognizable once the
tournament gets rolling the worst
tournament arcs will pit characters
against each other in hopes that the
action will distract from the mediocre
writing and even some of the best are
littered with constant interruptions or
[ __ ] out of having a proper winner like
every tournament arc is destined to
suddenly get a huge bout of anxiety and
trying to keep the audience's attention
and prematurely just ejaculates the next
story arc so I'm glad to say that
ironically one thing that makes academia
stakes standout is that it's a
tournament arc with minimal
interruptions and an actual winner in
the end mmm hold on I don't think you
quite heard me correctly so let me just
let me just try saying that again and
again see what's like in respect asunder
series was confident enough to engage
the audience right the way through to
the end with the core elements present
in his own tournament sure we were
shorter than many other arcs of its kind
but that's what it never made it boring
instead of having one or several
episodes per match we could get through
multiple matches in a single episode
which allowed even the matches no one
really cared about to be entertaining
without overstaying their welcome if
these kinds of matches where you really
have a chance to play around with your
matchups
because this setup is the perfect excuse
to have characters face off against each
other that you wouldn't normally see why
do you think a series like death battle
is so popular why are versus debates the
bread-and-butter of any internet
discussion and why is Mayweather vs
McGregor actually happening against all
odds
people like speculating over
hypothetical fights because hell it's
fun and you can settle them in your own
tournament arch importantly without the
need of setting up a real conflicts
between characters or properly
villainizing anyone in the two anime
fights video I've done I've broken down
many different ways to make a fight
engaging and this is the opportunity to
bring something unique with every fight
a clash of style the clash of
personality a clash of ideals even
without giving everyone a unique power
there are many ways to make an
interesting battle so academia shines
through cyber s'ti and ingenuity of
everyone's different quirks what's
important here though is that there's
more freedom with match outcomes it's
the safes aren't high and you can always
throw in a few curveballs and upsets
here and there because it's not the
outcome of a match that's important it's
how the match plays out this leads me to
the real reason academia does this arc
so well which is that the series uses
the tournament art format to build on
its core themes rather than distracts
from them the series has always been
about the simplistic view of heroes and
villains with each character on their
own unique journey to become the hero
they want to be it's their hero's
journey at stake here and nothing else
which is why I find it amazing that the
face can feel so intense when at the end
of the day this is nothing more than
your typical high school sports saving
superpowers the world isn't on the line
the winners don't find one piece losers
don't get relegated to the Shadow Realm
everything is entirely personal as we
get to see everyone's individual
narratives their drives their desires
their ambitions all clash in one place
and that's all that's really needed as
if you follow real sports no matter who
wins or loses in the end there is always
a story there every character has their
time in the spotlight so it's your
perfect opportunity for all their
personal stakes that have been set up
prior to property come to fruition and
academia manages to do this brilliantly
with a diverse and well-balanced car
shinzo who wanted a competition with an
air of mystery and malice ended up being
a sympathetic reflection of the
frustrations that you had to face when
he goes without work an Aurora cos very
valiant attempts not only cemented has a
relatable kid trying her absolutely best
to make life easier for her parents but
as a character that has actual potential
for strength only just see unable to
overcome the wall that is Bukka goes
insane drive to prove that he's number
one
but the highlight battle was without a
doubt of course deku versus Todoroki
which encapsulates everything my hero
academia is about we're going to this
fight knowing Todoroki troubled past
with his father why he's so determined
to beat death and while completely
rejecting his father's power and why
that's so important then that deku has a
relation with all my deku on the other
hand essentially uses the entire fight
to convince his opponents to stop
limiting him
and just accept himself for his own
being without living in the shadow of
the Father he so despises with our
context that seems like a stupid thing
to do why would you try to go to your
opponent's reaching their full potential
when you are more likely to lose which
he does
but while Dec who doesn't win
technically he succeeds in saving
Todoroki from his own personal conflict
possibly setting him on the right path
and this is exactly in line with dec
whose own hero's journey and everything
that he stands for he wants to be a
superhero a beacon of justice and a hero
isn't just a hero because they graduate
from hero school or get picked up by
hero organizations but it's their
actions that define the hero they want
to be from the beginning the price was
never about who won a lot but every
punch thrown every bone broken every
clash felt incredibly heavy as what we
are really seeing is the crash of two
people's life voyage and their own
values of being a hero
this goes for almost every major flight
in the tournament which goes back to
what I said before the series uses the
tournament arc to build on its own
themes not distract from them and that
is what makes this fight feel so goddamn
epic it's the reason why people will
remember this fight for years to come
why Rock Lee versus Gaara stunned us as
kids
why gone versus Hisoka became a modern
classic and while you skate versus two
Goro set presents for all tournament
arcs to come
it wasn't the tournament itself but it
was what the fights represented
we look at any real sporting event and
you see people crying emotional tears of
despair and joy when objectively you
could say cheer up it's just a game
it's just a medal it's just a piece of
metal but it isn't it's years of your
life practicing its your ambitions your
hopes and dreams and though you may try
again next year or in four years right
then and there you are caught in the
moment and it feels like the world to
you and it's this feeling this wave of
emotion that my hero academia captures
so brilliantly in its own fictional
sporting event because once again this
series continues to play - all of
shonan's most beloved tropes absolutely
right at the end of the day a tournament
arc is just the format a very effective
format to bringing out some of the best
and most exciting moments achievable in
the Shonan john rowe within such a
compact time frame but like everything
else it requires the same amount of
thought and preparation to make it truly
shine as with any other kind of
narrative arc done wrong and it's just
another generic excuse for bland action
but done right and it's an explosion of
every possible reason you could have to
be a shown in anime fan endless action
heroes villains rivalries epic showdown
hype that will blast you off the edge of
your seat excitement that brings you
back to your childlike innocence enough
adrenaline pumping through your veins to
get you through a marathon and moments
that will drop your jaw right down to
the floor why do I love tautomer narcs
why don't I love torment
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video now
before you say anything about me using
the job you can leave your opinions
right there on the corner makes the [ __ ]
I don't give because I sort of dull from
I hear academia has that be genuinely
good and if you want to experience
illegally I'll leave a link the
description for 14-day free charts
Funimation gun for those of you
interested the tournament archers are
still on sale and you can find them in
the link below or you can click on the
button at the end of the video and with
that says thank you very much suit
Thrones melt
Jerrica tell gay brown Vincent Mooney
giggle I see one today with you Maine
now can and everyone often patients
helping support me for this month and
making this video possible as you can
see I'll be back in England for the next
two months I don't know how I like the
list I will be back in America next
month for control experts and I am
getting there but anyway that's it for
me I've been gig up and I'll see you all
next time